l'idée ça va être de prélever un bloc de
sol qu'ils fassent
la largeur de beige sur la largeur de
bêche donc un bloc de sol on évite au
maximum en fait de saucissonner parce
que le risque c'est de couper des vers
de terre en plusieurs morceaux et après
on sera pas si ces issues d'un ou de
deux fers de terre d'eau quand on
enfonce la belge verticalement sur la
zone qui nous sommes la plus
représentative possible donc bien formés
le carré voilà maintenant on va sur le
côté sans marcher dessus oumar jamais ce
réseau nous on va prélever en fait plus
on fait vivre à sion et plus au vrai et
ensuite faire levier et maîtres queux et
donc faire levier pour m 1 1 seul bloc
bleu il ya du monde des beaux et plus
indécis que celui ci a été coupée donc
on va réajuster maintenant de manière à
récupérer pendant tout le volume de
cendre jusqu'à une profondeur de tâches
extra maintenant je mette la moutarde
donc on va commencer par on va mettre la
moitié puis on va voir comment ça se
fait au compte chèque bien donc on a mis
une cuillère à soupe en fait le moutarde
ça c'est un filtre bien dès le départ on
peut mettre toute la voie donc mais une
aide de minutes
l'intérêt de ça c'est que les années ci
qui sont descendus en profondeur c'est
quand on a enfoncé la dèche les
vibrations ça fait que les années sic
ont pu descendre en profondeur et avec
la galerie verticale ils peuvent
descendre jusqu'à 3 mètres de profondeur
dans ce cas pas dans ce cas-là ce que
justement on a eu d'aller de la roche et
donc la 6è des années site encore en
profondeur d'un le la moutarde va
arriver ça les honneurs voilà exactement
et puis du coup donc voir monter donc
maintenant en fait on va trier ce bloc
de sol et l'intérêt c'est vraiment
d'utiliser un bac noir de manière à ce
qu'on puisse vraiment toujours s'assurer
qu'on voit bien ce qu'il ya au fond
d'eux au fond du bac en flattant au
final on va compter le nombre de vers de
terre qu'on va obtenir dans ce dans ce
bloc de sol et après on va multiplier sa
part un coefficient pour pouvoir amener
ça en fait au mètre carré
l'intérêt de cette méthode là c'est
qu'elle est facile à mettre en oeuvre on
voit bien il faut juste une bêche et
puis on complète avec de la moutarde
pour être sûr de récupérer tous les
années sic mais elle est facile à mettre
en place et donc du coup vous vous
pouvez aussi vous faire votre propre
diagnostic exactement là où il faut
cette vigilance et il faut pas aller
n'importe quand on s'amuse pas à faire
ce que vous disiez tout à l'heure on
s'amuse panne en plein été par exemple
parce qu'effectivement les vers de terre
ils seront potentiellement lamta qui
seront vraiment en profondeur et 6 soit
endormi même si vous mettez en fait de
la moutarde
ça va pas les réveiller l'idée c'est de
2 effectivement ne pas trop s'éloigner
de l'endroit où on a pu faire un premier
prélèvement
donc on ce n'est pas juste à côté mais
pas très loin tout l'état
et donc toujours travaillé sur un fond
noir c'est ça en fait dès qu'on a des
cons de bien nettoyer ça donc c'est une
étape qui normalement doit prendre deux
milliards entre le moment où on prélève
qui au nom trice une demi heure trois
quart d'heure up en fait faut toujours
les maîtres d'enfin dans de l'eau c'est
ça facilite la la le fait qu'on
contourner les toits en fait contrôler
les dents dont le salon permet de
nettoyer puis mais il faut toujours être
choqué parce qu'effectivement les petits
on voit bien certaines fois ce n'est pas
facile à voir donc maintenant on va
compter et puis on va pouvoir faire un
premier diagnostic en fait la qualité
biologique
le fait de préserver la couverture de
sol systématiquement ça va améliorer les
conditions d'habitat et puis de
nourriture pour pour les vers de terre
est plate est donc ça va être positif
pour tout le monde donc on va compter
maintenant ensemble de trois 3 années si
stricte 12 et il va falloir multiplier
maintenant par 25 donc 12 soit 25 300
francs 300 individus 300 individus
sachant que quand on regarde en fait à
l'échelle française
le nombre d'individus qu'on peut avoir
un système cultivées en moyenne on est à
200 et quelques individus la médiane et
280 donc là vous êtes largement au
dessus